what is the meditation process
specifically look like dead simple so I
use a what I call just breathe so it was
born of Mark Devine's box breathing at
least he was the one that introduced it
to me he preaches do it for equal parts
so you've got the inhale is the exact
same length as the inhale hold exact
same length is the exhale exact same
length as the exhale hold now doing that
made me feel out of breath I just felt
weird so what I started doing was I'm
going to maximize the pleasure in each
part of the breath cycle so for me it
happens to be medium inhale a very short
inhale hold a rapid exhale I just let
the arrow and then a very prolonged
exhale hole and that Rhythm feels
awesome and I do that for 10 or 15
minutes and I can get into an alpha wave
stay to feel calm creative it just feels
awesome people that haven't tried
meditation or tried it but never got to
the part where it feels awesome my heart
breaks for them it is a tool I rejected
for so many years because it felt wussy
to me and remember I'm the guy that had
to learn to toughen up so I feared that
that was like backwards momentum and so
finally when Mark divine and looked to
me and was basically like stop being an
idiot and try this and he's like this
tough ass Navy SEAL yeah I thought all
right I'm gonna try and then it changed
my life so I have a slightly different
take on meditation and if you've been
struggling with meditation in your life
this might help I first thought believe
in the power of meditation I believe the
science I believe all the studies and I
used to judge myself and feel really bad
about it because I I felt like I
couldn't meditate I would sit there on
the couch or on the pillow or on the bed
or lie down and I never felt anything
when I was meditated I could sit and I
could be present and I could I could I
could do it and then and I could sit
there for 20 minutes and it felt like 20
minutes
but I never felt any different I mean
that was where it started to shift for
me is not that I didn't feel anything in
the moment but never felt any different
coming out and I've meditated with some
of the
the the best meditation teachers
um on the planet and it's never really
led to an impact for me uh in the moment
or afterwards or sustained and I again
would judge myself really harshly like
hey I mean I want to make this work how
do I make this work I Believe In The
Sciences go and make it work
what I've distilled it down to is into
two parts one is a lot of meditation a
lot of benefits I believe from
meditation are really just about being
present and being Mindful and that is
something that I can do a lot more
naturally than maybe most people and I
don't find a lot of benefit in it
because I'm more there than not so I I'm
85 present 15 future focused and zero
percent past focus when you are thinking
about the past it's usually really
negative way sometimes we like pass Look
Backwards into the past and it's
gratitude and and remembering great
memories and
um you know looking all the great things
we've done but for the most part when
you look backwards it's negative it's
regrets it's I wish I did this or why
did that person do that to me or I wish
I had said something different we're
we're looking negatively on our past
mostly through the lens of regret and
what you did or what other people did
and when you're looking forward
entrepreneurs love looking forward and
the vision and the building what you can
create and all the amazing things but a
lot of looking forward is also
uncertainty in Stress and Anxiety in
what may happen and what could happen
and what might happen if x happens and
just we're stuck in these negative Loops
a lot of the backwards thinking is
negative through the lens of regret and
a lot of the Forward Thinking is
negative through the lens of anxiety
stress and worry and so that's where hey
if you're present-minded you're going to
be a lot happier you're going to be a
lot more focused right if you're just
thinking about what you should have done
or what might happen to you you're not
actually able to be productive and get
stuff out right now in the present and
so the the job becomes how do I stay
present and I think a lot of that is
accomplished through meditation for most
people if you're if you're in a state of
stress thinking about the regret of the
past or anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focusing on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
that can help calm you down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to
be able to be productive uh solve the
problem be happy because you're being
more present so for me that's actually
quite easy I'm in the present uh a lot
more than anywhere else and I used to
think it as a negative a friend of mine
used to make fun of me for having a bad
memory he's like you're such a bad
memory it's like and I later realized I
I don't have a bad memory I I want to
remember what's important to me but two
I'm not living in the past like I don't
care about what happened I'm looking at
right now today I don't know what day it
is I don't know what day it is I don't
know I I know it's 2022 when recording
this I'd have to think about what month
it is
I don't know what I'm doing after
recording this video I don't know what I
did yesterday I don't know what I'm
doing tomorrow let alone once I press
stop on this video I am here with you
this is this is my entire attention is
making this video right now that's it
this is this is the present moment for
me and what I've discovered is
this is meditation
at least the the portion of it where
you're getting back to present moment if
that's one of the main benefits of
meditation then this is meditation for
me I'm only in the present moment right
now being here talking with you guys and
that's it
and I realized that most of my life is
lived like that yes I love planning for
where I'm gonna go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in in
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend gonna look like
weekend I don't even know what I'm doing
in the next hour let alone what I'm
doing this weekend and when people ask
me on a Monday how was your weekend like
I don't know
that was that was that was yesterday
that was two days ago I'm I got stuff to
do right now I'm working on my life
right now and and not just work even
just enjoying even just life even just
me spending time with with my wife or my
son or on a trip it's like let's enjoy
this moment where we're at right now and
so if that's you I would introduce the
idea of hey that's a different
perspective shift like maybe you are
meditating right now and you might be
over judging yourself because if you're
in the present that's one of the biggest
benefits one of my favorite things to do
every morning is I go on a belief walk
and I found when a lot of people would
say oh I get my best ideas when I'm
meditate if I get creative breakthroughs
when I'm meditating part of that that I
believe is hey you've unblocked yourself
from the past and the future the regrets
of the past the stress of the future to
get back to present which then calms you
down to then that should be more
creative and solve the problem I found I
wasn't getting I wasn't really getting
answers I wasn't getting Solutions I
wasn't being very creative of sitting
down lying down and having my body be
still where I get a lot more of my
energy and creativity and ideas when I'm
moving so I get a lot of ideas
when I'm walking so I do a belief walk
every morning which is 30 to 60 minutes
I'll take the dogs out and then I'll go
for a walk usually the Tim Hortons grab
myself a coffee Canadian coffee brain
here and
No Agenda just think about what what am
I doing today you know what what day is
it what I want to accomplish today uh
taking some fresh air get a fresh
perspective and the the act of moving I
find gets my creativity flowing a lot
more I get ideas in the shower you know
when I'm when I'm moving have you got
ideas in the shower I think that's
meditation maybe it's a different
version of it a different definition of
it but I think that's meditation where
you can calm down when you can focus on
present and you get some great ideas to
come I'm selling my place we just bought
a new house we're selling this place and
the studio looks a little different
normally I'm filming in my car because
we're running some errands or my regular
studio and to get this place ready to
sell you you know we wanted to have a a
place that everybody could connect to
and so what my agent did was make an
office in a different room and I'm
sitting down and I have not sat down for
two years I don't know my last time I
like sat down to actually work and and
you might even notice me like I'm
Shuffling around a little bit like I
like to move normally I'm on a
trampoline and I'm bouncing 20 to 40 000
times a day and I got that because I
would find that when I did phone calls I
would much rather stand up and walk
around the office than just sit down and
so I'm a lot more creative and have a
lot more energy when I'm moving and
maybe that movement in my energy creates
movement in you know brain energy and
capacity and thinking creativity as well
but all of that is my form of meditation
and so any time that I would challenge
you to at least consider the fact that
anytime that you're present
anytime that you are focused on
something that you can consider that
part of the benefits of meditation
the second part of meditation that I
haven't fully connected to yet and I
don't have a solution for yet is when
you access theta waves and that's
basically when you're bouncing between
conscious and subconscious and where you
feel like
time flies so for me when I sit down or
lie down doing a meditation
if it's 20 minutes it feels like 20
minutes and I don't think I'm hitting
any Theta levels
um I can sit there and be present and
focus on my breath or you know I've
chewed a cookie for half an hour or an
hour and never swallowed it you know
like the focus and the presence I can do
but it still feels like it's 20 minutes
or half an hour or an hour I've never
had a I sat down for an hour and I felt
like it was I was only on for five
minutes
I get that more through the work that
I'm doing I get that more
um I recently did a six hour uh q a with
Tom bilyu's impact community
on his Discord and
it was six hours I didn't go to the
bathroom I didn't take a break I was I
was reading the questions and answering
the questions my throat was burning
didn't even notice it till the end and
had that six hours flew where that felt
if you asked me how long was it I would
have said I don't know it was like 20
minutes half an hour like six hours six
hours later still going and then we
eventually wrapped it up because it
needs to go to dinner
my wife where I said yeah I'm gonna do
this short little q a and turned out to
be six hours
so maybe that's even a better form of
meditation maybe maybe when you're in
your purpose and doing great work and
time flies because you're having fun
maybe that is a better form of
meditation for you if you struggle with
just sitting down and meditating maybe
doing that work is healing you know I
think a lot of people meditate to heal
and I think of a part of why that could
work is because you're again removing
the stress of the past of the regret of
the past and removing the anxiety and
stress of the future and when your
body's all stressed out it's not going
to heal right but when you get back to
present and remove the stress you create
the conditions for healing in your body
well I remember when I broke my neck in
2019 and I kept doing my tour I kept
staying on it because I wanted to be
around entrepreneurs I wanted to keep
doing the I could have canceled the tour
wouldn't have been a big deal but that
became healing for me in feeling like I
was serving that I was helping sitting
at the front of a room for four hours
with
immobilized neck brace on ice packs you
know on my neck two or three pillows
behind me and I couldn't move for four
hours but just talk
that became healing for me
and so
at least what's helped me for where I'm
at right now I'm totally open to to new
experiences and being changed and and
you know swaying my opinion before I'm
at right now
staying present
and doing
not just the work but doing activities
that you enjoy that you feel are in
service to others that you feel like
you're living your purpose that you feel
like you're having an impact think about
the things that you love doing where
where hours get lost I'm not talking
about like opening your phone and
scrolling through Instagram when you
realize that two hours have passed and
like how did I just waste all this time
not that but
in service of others and helping to see
I'm moving around right now I gotta move
I can't sit still
I don't like it when I get in creative
ideas I gotta move I play with my ring
you know they got the ring is all over
the place it's not just on my finger
this this gives me more creativity like
the motion creates more creativity for
me
and so if you find those things where
you love doing it's in service to others
is helping people time gets lost and you
feel it in your heart and your soul that
this is the right thing for you to be
doing for where you're at right now
that maybe that's you know maybe just
maybe that's the form of meditation that
you need the most
that
by staying present and helping others
and being in service maybe that's all
the healing that you need
maybe that is the present mind that you
need maybe that is the focus that you
need maybe that is the meditation that
you're already doing
and if that gives you some extra
perspective or a different view on
meditation than what you might hear
other places I hope that helps maybe
judge yourself a little bit less or
maybe lean into something that you
thought didn't exist because it
certainly played a huge impact on my
life and thank you for allowing me to
share the story with you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
if somebody's giving you advice about
something that they have not done in
their own life then they have basically
a zero believability score and somebody
has a zero believability score shouldn't
be pushing their idea like they know
something they should be asking a lot of
questions now when you're talking to
somebody that's done and Ray dalio
saying is three times or more if they've
successfully done something three times
or more than they have believability in
that area so you want to find people
that have believability that really know
what they're talking about and
then you should listen you should ask a
lot of questions you should really come
to understand it if they haven't done
that they may still have amazing ideas
but what you need because the
um you know sometimes a novice has
really fresh insights because they're
just not stuck in the dogmatic ways of
thinking that experts usually get into
but you need to be thinking about it
differently so rather than listening to
their conclusions you should be trying
to understand their methodology how did
they get there what is their process
their reasoning for making the statement
that they're making now if their
reasoning is sound then their conclusion
may very well be worthwhile but you have
to understand their reasoning so one of
those two things so either they are an
expert in that area and thusly you
should listen or they are not and you
should only be thinking about what their
process was to get to that conclusion
and then you have to be able to derive
your own assessment as to whether or not
you should listen to them there's not
going to be anything more empirical than
that if you want to do something
extraordinary you have one job leave
your fellow humans in ah
now when you think about holy my
job as a parent as an entrepreneur as an
athlete as a speaker as a whatever you
want to be
you've got to get so good at that thing
that when people see you do it you make
them experience the most potent human
emotion and that is awe
to get that good
is a terrifying journey of
self-discovery and confronting who you
really are
because you cannot make change until you
acknowledge where you're actually at
now why because it's not some new age
woo thing it is for real like if you
understand where you're weak then you
know where to spend your time building
skills to me the gap between where you
are now and where you want to go is a
gap of skill set
and once I realized that and I made the
choice to believe that this whole brain
plasticity thing was real even though it
was being hotly debated then I could
shift my self-esteem from being smart
right good Worthy
to being that of the learner
the learner is the only identity that I
have ever found
that is anti-fragile as Naseem taleb
says things that are robust that are
strong that are tough
that can take just a lot of abuse before
they break they are still ultimately
defined by their Breaking Point
something that is anti-fragile on the
other hand is something that the more
you attack it the more it is pounded on
the stronger it gets now imagine being
able to build a belief system
the thing that you build your
self-esteem around if all of that were
tied to something that is truly
anti-fragile that the more somebody
comes after it the more robust it
becomes
being a learner is that answer we went
through a whole debate about what is the
next company going to be and it was one
of those where it had to be something
that we cared about you know we had
started this whole gyration of selling
the technology company because I was so
pissed and so tired of chasing money and
I wanted to do something that I believed
in I wanted to do something that
mattered that had impact so the only
reason that I was interested in getting
into nutrition was because I felt that
it one it could save the two people that
I was most worried about in the world
and two I thought that it could address
what I saw as the greatest Health the
greatest Health crisis we face as a
species quite frankly what it's really
going to take for you to get to that
next level is to understand that the
person that you are has gotten you as
far as is ever going to get you so
you've got to become a new person you
literally have to adapt
now the great news is like we talked to
my first talk that is what humans are
wired to do humans are the ultimate
adaptation machine the reason that we
are the only species that you can find
in every corner of the globe at one
point James Cameron was literally at the
bottom of the Marianas Trench we have
sent human beings to the Moon
we are going to send human beings to
Mars
and the reason we're going to be able to
do that is we can adapt to our
surroundings
there was a woman who swam the bearing
straight
really think about this the Bering
Strait is the space between Russia and
Alaska so you can imagine it's not quite
a swim in the Bahamas
to make the swim
she had to change
her fat
from what's known as white adipose
tissue
to Brown fat
Brown fat is more thermogenic so it
actually kicks off heat
to do that for over a year she had to
expose herself routinely to cold
temperatures sleeping in the winters in
Alaska with the window open
but in doing that she actually put her
body through an adaptation response her
body got the message adapt or die so it
adapted and when you're willing to put
yourself under those kinds of stresses
to become that new thing you want to
become to be the new person that you
want to be to go farther than anyone you
know has ever gone to be the goat it is
possible
but it demands a price
it Demands a price
and what this weekend is about it's
about you deciding for yourself
where do you want to go
and what price are you willing to pay to
get there
there's no right answer
there's no wrong answer
there's just clarity
don't judge yourself if you don't want
to play on a world stage
don't judge yourself if you're not
willing to pay an extraordinary price
just get the clarity of what you want
and what you need to do to get there
when you do that then you're going to be
able to construct a narrative about who
you are
and that narrative becomes everything
fulfillment is what matters
it is a neurochemistry state
the game that you're playing is not
success it is not money it is not legacy
it is neuro chemistry it's feeling good
about yourself right now today in this
moment now
the absolute foundational building block
to fulfillment is progress now it I
don't mean progress in worldly Pursuits
I mean humans are an active species that
are absolutely designed to learn adapt
and grow we are the ultimate adaptation
machine now when Nature wants us to do
something it incentivizes that thing
with pleasure so if we're the ultimate
adaptation machine designed to learn
grow and get better then it's going to
make that process intensely pleasurable
now what it doesn't incentivize is the
obsession over where other people are
whether or not we have UniQue Ideas
whether or not we're valuable none of
that is going to bring you Joy okay as
they say comparison is the thief of Joy
so hey if you really want to with
yourself jump in the Instagram feed and
look how other people are crushing it
and obsess over that
if on the other hand you want to really
have a deep and Lasting sense of
fulfillment jump in the Instagram feed
find people that motivate and inspire
you to be a better version of yourself
not to attain worldly success but to
actuate your potential to ask yourself a
very simple question what is it that I
am excited by what am I motivated by
what jazz is me up regardless of whether
or not a jazz is anybody else up and now
I'm gonna go get good at that thing and
that progress is the foundational
building block of happiness I exactly
what I wanted I had my why I
[Music]
about goals they have to be incredibly
specific and my goal was to end
metabolic disease
not sell a lot of protein bars that was
not the goal I wanted to end metabolic
disease and that informed every choice
that we made as entrepreneurs every time
that we had to answer a hard question
one that might impact profitability or
how late we were going to have to work
or what we were going to have to do and
it almost always was difficult including
by the way we had to become our own
manufacturers which we did not want to
do
we wanted to Outsource it we just wanted
to be marketers but nobody would make
the bar for us
or they would but they said that we had
to add sugar to it and we asked a simple
question will that help end metabolic
disease yes or no if yes we'll do it if
no we won't and it wouldn't so we didn't
it starts with that specific goal
and then because I had my why my hands
cramping closed in the face of doing
something to save my mom and my sister
it was not a hard choice in fact I
wouldn't have been able to look myself
in the eye and say I was not able to
help them
because it was hurting my hands
right it sounds ridiculous when you say
it like that but most people don't have
a personal tie to what they're doing
Mother Teresa has an amazing quote no
one will act for the many
but people will ask for the one
and so as you guys go into your jobs and
you think about what you're trying to do
find a way to stop making it a job find
a way to make it a calling a vocation
something that really meets that why
your desire to connect or do something
great for people motivation you have to
want it it has to be something that you
were on fire for literally as you were
describing it I was like oh my God I
would study so much I would Ace this
exam you have no idea I would absolutely
kill this
because that's my identity so why is it
that you want to do this is it that you
want to be the best is it just the
promotion if it's the promotion and this
is just about money what does that mean
why does it matter what are you going to
do with the money are you the first
person in your family to be promoted
that far are you setting an example for
your son or your daughter like when you
attach it to something that really
matters like for me it's like I'm gonna
dominate wherever you put me I'm going
to dominate that's just my thing my
identity is so wrapped up in outworking
everybody else I love it so I love going
hard learning putting more time and
energy my thing is part of my identity
you ready for the secret part of my
identity is like I will work so hard at
something that people will just assume
I'm naturally gifted at that thing
because the alternative to believe that
I'm spending
40 hours a week 40 hours a week on top
of my full-time job to study for that
thing people they won't believe that I
would put that kind of energy and effort
into something
it will and so to them it just looks
like magic now I love that so much that
it becomes very easy for me to use
identity statements Okay so we've got
motivation
we're getting amped about it it matters
to us for some reason now we've got
identity statements I'm the type of
person that I'm the type of person that
works so hard people assume it's magic
I'm the type of person that works so
hard at something that people just
assume I'm naturally talented okay I
love that I love saying that about
myself I love knowing that it's true I
love knowing that I can trust myself to
put in the time and the energy to own it
because I'm the type of person that
knows information is really power and
that if I go in and I work and I get
better at this thing that I'm going to
be able to outperform other people right
skills have utility this is one of the
most common frames ever worth
being good enough being right being
smart
because these are very fragile ways to
think of yourself and I understand the
Temptation because it feels really good
when you do feel worthy it feels really
good when you are right it feels really
good to actually be the best at
something
but the truth of the world just the
truth of the world it is this way
you're always going to encounter
somebody better stronger faster more
Pious more worthy more whatever
so if you live in a world of comparison
it will rob you of your joy
even people who like Michael Jordan if
you put him right now up against
most rookies the rookies gonna win
rookies younger faster hungrier
Michael's just lost the step he's gotten
old
so if he were trying to make his life
about his glory in that period let's say
he lives 80 years if he's living for the
glory of 20 years that's the most
heartbreaking life I can imagine
so you're going to move in and out of
these moments where you are a badass to
where you're not a badass
don't value yourself for that
value yourself for something that is
anti-fragile
being smart being right being good being
worthy they are very fragile things
because sometimes you won't be it simply
is this way
valuing yourself for being a learner on
the other hand for trying
that's anti-fragile because the more
somebody attacks you for being dumb but
you build your self-esteem around
learning
the first thing I think when someone
says I'm dumb is awesome in what way
because I view myself in these 10-year
windows and I know the same people that
were laughing at me
when I became an entrepreneur knew
nothing about it and I was who's the kid
in the server room and I was the only
one with an office that had no windows
and there were like nine other computers
in my room and nobody knew who I was and
the only contribution I made the phone
calls was to say goodbye at the end of a
conference call I'm not kidding
Ten Years Later
I own
a billion dollar business
who the is laughing now
but it only worked because I didn't mind
looking stupid it only worked because I
wasn't asking myself whether I was
worthy or whether I deserved it I just
asked myself am I leaving it all out in
the field yes or no am I learning yes or
no and if I'm not I didn't go oh that
makes me a bad person I went I need to
change my actions to get a different
result
and once you start thinking like that
and you literally value yourself for how
hard you're trying how much you're
learning how willing you are to accept
when you fall on your face so you don't
try to get out from under it or campaign
to convince people that you're better
than you really are found where you're
at
because once you're real about it then
you can make progress but if your energy
Cycles go to yourself you'll
never get out of it humans are designed
to adapt we are the ultimate adaptation
machine we can learn anything we set our
minds to now you may not want to learn
it and that's good evidence that this is
not a Fascination that's going to turn
into a passion this is something that
you should avoid but if you can answer
the question affirmatively that do I
want to know more about this than anyone
else in the world if the answer is yes
that's a path to go down because once
you're saying yes to that then you're
going to go in and learn the things you
need to do to become extraordinary and
if you're willing to put in the effort
while it may take you longer than
somebody else you will get there in the
end if you keep at it keep at it keep at
it because the people that win are not
the smartest
it is always the people that keep at it
it's the people that persevere that's
just truth man now being smart helps yay
um I really wish I was a lot smarter so
but I know that I'll beat 99.99 of the
people that play regardless of level of
intelligence because most people just
drop out once you have your goal then
you can work backwards to what you need
to do in order to accomplish that goal
and that is the chasm of adaptation
it's the acquisition of skill set
it's getting better at something it's
becoming capable of something that you
weren't capable of before
but that change
the fear of the unknown
is the thing that paralyzes people
so I want to go back to what I said
earlier
you all meet minimum requirements
and I really mean that I don't want you
to wonder if somebody believes in you
I believe in you
I've seen a lot of people
reach for the stars and fail I've seen a
lot of people reach for the stars and
make it
I have a pretty good sense
of what it takes for people to get there
so when I say that you guys meet minimum
requirements I really mean it
and I want that to liberate you
but what I wanted to liberate you to do
is to figure out why it's not enough
because I didn't just change anyone's
life with that phrase but I should have
that should be all you need to know
but there are other things stuck in your
perception of who you are in the lens by
which you view this world that convinces
you that you can't make it remember that
just 15 years earlier
I got out of bed solely out of Shame
my mother thought I was going to fail my
father-in-law did not want me to marry
his daughter
Brick by Brick
day after day I transformed myself it
was not an uncovering of something that
was real and already there it was simply
acknowledging I am a hopelessly average
human
but humans are the ultimate adaptation
machine
so I can change I can become whatever I
want and I just became single-mindedly
focused on how much I could grow and now
that I was getting value and self-esteem
out of growing instead of out of being
everything in my life changed
so 15 years later
my father-in-law visits
the U.S for the first time since we
started Quest
and I'm taking him around the production
floor
and there's three hundred thousand
square feet there's 800 employees the
bars are coming off the line at 1.5
million a day people are coming up and
thanking me for having a job and for the
way that we run the company and all that
and I turned to him and I said Andreas
do you remember asking me how I was
going to take care of your daughter
and he said yes
and I said how am I doing
and he just burst into tears
and the punch line of that story
it does not matter who you are today
the only thing that matters is who you
want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there we all come to a relationship
with like expectations about how we
think people should act and
unfortunately we don't recognize our
expectations as expectations we
recognize them as truth this is how the
world is it is how the world should be
and when somebody we think that they
have those same beliefs and values and
rules and all that and so given this
scenario there's only one way to act
that is certainly obvious and so when
the person doesn't act like that we take
it personally like whoa do you not
respect me do you not love me do not
care about me and it just isn't that
they have a different set of beliefs and
rules there's enough Nuance difference
that they're not if they're intending to
hurt you you have a whole different set
of problems but assuming that they're
not intending to hurt you then you have
a communication problem so Lisa and I
actually Define our terms so we have a
few words in our marriage that they mean
something so if I say hey baby it's
important to me that you leave that you
know glass of water on the table
then there she just wouldn't move it
period simple as like the the word
important like comes in all caps with
exclamation points glowing red like
that's like when we say it like it's a
drop whatever you're doing like it's
important that you do XYZ now the big
thing is when you define a word like
that you can't ever abuse it so like I
would never say it's important to me
that you leave you know it's got to be
it's just extraordinary like how many
times do I tell her something's
important in a year
I don't know six seven times in a year
so it's like it's really got to be
limited and then another one is promise
if I say I promise I'm gonna do that
dude I'm going to do that like there's
no two ways about it so you never throw
around promise ever under any
circumstance and so dude it's like you
really really have to be hardcore and so
and the other way that we use promises
um if if uh she says you know how does
this dress look on me I'm like yeah it
looks great and she's like you promise
then it's like all right all right it
makes you look fat what can I say you
know I mean it's like but then you you
cut to like the chase on something now
the thing is you can't say that all the
time you can't be like how's this dress
make me look fine promise uh what do you
think of this dinner you like it yeah I
love it promise like if you're doing
that it loses everything totally but if
you're saving it for like in fact God I
almost don't remember the last time I
asked Lisa to promise something like
that
um but you know that you haven't we
certainly use it more in the early days
of our marriage but even then like how
many times a year three or four I mean
it's like but it really forces you to
respect these things you make sacred in
your relationship the man on top of the
mountain didn't fall there it's so
tempting to look at people that have
achieved the extraordinary and dismiss
them as being more talented than you
better than you but what you need to see
is the simple truth
they've worked harder than you
they've earned something that you
haven't yet earned but here's the great
news that's empowering once you
understand that they've just busted ass
once you understand that they've just
put in an inhuman amount of work and
that the only thing that distinguishes
the people that are on top of the
mountain the people that have really
done something that's going to last is
that they put in the effort they work on
themselves they understand that through
discipline and effort over time
that we can get better that is the human
condition that is the thing that I find
most beautiful about being a person is
it doesn't matter if you're bad today it
doesn't matter where you start it only
matters where you're willing to go and
the price that you're willing to pay to
get there and once you buckle down and
you assure yourself and back it up with
action that you're willing to pay any
price to achieve the things that you
want to achieve
then you really be living a limitless
life for the person who's stuck for the
guy or gal who's in the cubicle who's
hates their job is in a dysfunctional
relationship is in debt whatever the
case may be desperately wants a way out
a way forward a Lifeline where does that
process begin for you like what is the
advice that you give that person so it
begins with believing or acknowledging
that humans are the ultimate adaptation
machine so the the thing that has made
us the apex predator is not that we're
stronger it's not even that we're
smarter in fact the the quote often
attributed to Darwin is that oh it's the
survival of the fittest he actually
didn't say that what he did say was it's
not the strongest of the species that
survived nor the most intelligent but
rather the most adaptive to change now
the reason that humans are the Apex of
all apexes is because we are the most
adaptive species to change so if you
know that then it becomes infinitely
less important who you are today and
what matters is who do you want to
become and what price and the price
being the time and energy that you're
going to put into acquiring the skills
to become that person so imagine the
person that you want to be how would
they act and then start acting like that
if the person that you want to be would
leave their job and you know regardless
of whether they had a safety net burn
the ships and go after something new
then that's what you should do if the
person that you want to be would start
working nights and weekends because they
very much value having a stable income
that they can provide for their family
or themselves whatever but are going to
be disciplined and spend nights and
weekends to get the skill set to go be
more valuable somewhere else or to start
their own company whatever then do that
Elon Musk talks about in his business
it's all about breaking things down to
the physics
if you sell the people
the physics in your world is psychology
and understanding what motivates them
so your company needs to have a why
if you know Simon sinek and His
Brilliant book start with why
you'll know what we're talking about the
Golden Circle
most people know what they do they may
even know how they do it but they
oftentimes don't know why they do it
why did we launch Quest Nutrition
because we wanted to end metabolic
disease
nobody knew that from looking at a
protein bar
but our marketing material was about
that we didn't do features and benefits
we said stop sacrificing
we said you should hold food companies
to a new standard it's ridiculous that
food companies aren't
engineering new equipment to make food
that's both good for you and delicious
it's just ridiculous nobody's held their
feet to the fire people have been buying
the same junk products for years they're
not going to change unless you force
them to and so we came along and said
we're going to be the bearer of
Standards we know why we're doing what
we're doing so I can't release a product
that has sugar in it why because that's
not going to end metabolic disease and
that is my driver I show up to work
every day not thinking about making it
rain and counting my money I'm not
swimming in it like Scrooge McDuck I'm
coming every day thinking about two
people my mom and my sister
and I ask a very simple question is this
advantageous for my mom and my sister
yes or no if it is I do it if it's not I
don't now a lot of times what's
advantageous for my mom and my sister
was really expensive it was super
annoying to have to do it because it was
like you watch your margins like oh God
but it becomes an easy filter and every
business has to have a filter every
business needs to know what they say yes
to and what they say no to and if you
don't have that blinding Guiding Light
when you scale you will fall apart
and the reason you will fall apart your
customers won't know who you are they
won't know how to communicate your
message to somebody else your employees
won't know who you are they won't know
what to communicate to each other let
alone the outside world
so it has got to be blinding you have to
be able to write it down it has to be
super clear it's got to be direct and
it's got to be meaningful and it has to
be real
it's got to actually be something that
drives you what we all have to
understand is at the end of the day the
only thing that matters is how good is
your product whether you're trying to
build a company or you're trying to be a
kick-ass employee or you're trying to be
the best parent of all time at the end
of the day the only thing that matters
is getting good the only thing that
matters is actually delivering an
extraordinary performance until you get
to that point where you can actually
knock it out of the park until you get
to the point where you can Captivate
people with what you're able to do you
haven't gotten anywhere if you want to
be great if you want to leave a legacy
if you want to be remembered you've got
to focus on the acquisition of skills
you have to focus on actually getting
good that's the only thing that's really
going to capture people's imagination
now you've had like I have you've had
extraordinary people sitting across from
you I've been blessed to have you sit
across from me today and I'm curious
if there was a common uh denominator
between all of these people or what have
you learned that surprised you in doing
the show so far the thing that's really
surprised me is that it is so consistent
that which is what what has made them
all successful and their ability to
articulate it they use different words
some people come at it from different
angles everybody has something fresh I
heard a quote one time and it so
terrifies me this in fact over a long
enough time period people are going to
hear this quote from me so many times
because seriously man I'm not joking
this scares me and it scares me enough
that it it has a daily place in my life
and that is genius is a young man's game
and when I heard that quote I thought
whoa the one thing that all of us touch
for the briefest of moments is youth and
if you're lucky what you'll get is a
whole lot of middle age and then some
old age but you don't get a lot of Youth
and so I just thought oh that's really
scary and they were basing it on the
number of people that win Nobel prizes
it's almost always for work they did in
their 20s and 30s almost always and I
thought uh I don't like that and so
looking at why that and the reason I
guess this is important to say the
reason that I didn't like it was I felt
that my youth was really whipping by and
I hadn't accomplished the things that I
wanted to accomplish so if I'm you know
my youth is whooshing by me how do I
make sure that I can access genius at
any time that an on a genius shorthand
for like playing at the absolute best of
your game and really changing things
like really having an impact this is one
thing I think you and I share like no
I want to have impact on the
world so if I just wanted to be rich
Lisa and I would have bought an island
and retired you know years ago so
clearly there's something more that's
motivating me in that thing is impact
and really touching lives so it's like
wanting to be able to do that I don't
want to say well I had this brief window
in my youth and I either did or didn't
make use of it but even if I did I don't
want the rest of my life to be looking
back on that so another quote that
drives me your future should always be
bigger than your past so all right
you've got genius is a young man's game
and a personal belief of mine that you
you should always be looking towards
doing something more than you've ever
done and so you put those two together
and I just knew I had to solve for that
problem
and the only solution that I have for it
is switching things up like you said to
live at the edges and the same book was
talking about the people that do end up
getting either multiple Nobel prizes or
prizes for work they did later is it's
people that would routinely change so
that they would have these two
overlapping areas so like chemistry and
physics and like where those two meet
like there's new discoveries and new
ways to challenge your own thinking and
so always staying fresh always
challenging my own thinking always
looking at how am I wrong most people go
into an Endeavor with the confirmation
bias in fact you just brought that up so
it's like I'm so aware that by Nature
like everybody I just want to be told
how right I am how amazing the way that
I'm thinking is and because it feels
good right that feels awesome what makes
you happy
the the easy answer and the most
truthful answer is time with my wife the
other answer to what makes me happy
there's really two things so time with
my wife and then the pursuit which I'll
put in all caps right so the pursuit of
whatever the pursuit of getting better
the pursuit of impacting the world the
pursuit of building something big that
that matters the pursuit maybe I never
get it I don't care about that I care
about the pursuit I care about whether
sincerely I'm actually trying to make it
happen not yeah not just like
empty dreams but like for real I'm
actually giving myself over to this and
I spent a lot of time in the inner
cities I Big Brother for this one kid
for eight and a half years completely
changed my life and then having 1400
employees and about a thousand of which
grew up hard in the inner cities hard I
mean most of them grew up in Compton I
mean it was just some of the most
extraordinary stories I've ever heard
and I realize that those people are as
extraordinary as anybody Barack Obama
um Oprah Winfrey
um Tony Robbins like they all those same
raw materials exist in people in the
inner cities that nobody believes in
nobody think will ever go anywhere and
they won't because they don't believe in
themselves and so we were talking at our
most honest like what what are we really
driven by and I'm driven by that moment
of Awakening which I had in my own life
where I finally realized wait I can
learn new things so just because I'm not
good today doesn't mean I can't be good
tomorrow and and that filled me with so
much excitement I want to see that in
other people and I want to see what the
world looks like when other people
realize wait a second that Steve Jobs
quote that the world is made by people
no smarter than you is actually true and
so if you're believing that these people
are smarter than you because you did bad
on your SATs I'm just going to tell you
right now stop so you can develop
yourself so my obsession became that
humans are the ultimate adaptation
machine we are literally Wired from the
ground up
in order to grow and improve under
stress and pressure so it's like What's
the phrase pressure can burst pipes but
it also creates diamonds so it's like
you need the pressure and yes it can
hurt but it can also make something
amazing if you're willing to put
yourself in that situation so it's a
weird twist of fate that humans
um in order to build the muscle you
first have to tear it right yeah so but
once you accept that that's how it works
you can do extraordinary things I am not
a born entrepreneur now there are many
people that consider themselves a born
entrepreneur I am not one of them I know
that there were kids out there that had
lemonade stands when they were like six
months old they couldn't hold their head
up but they could sell that was not me I
was totally when it came to
stuff like that I had a paper route
and they gave your money in two ways one
they just gave you sort of a blanket
weekly payment for delivering the paper
but then the other part of it was you
were supposed to go collect that money
and I was too afraid to knock on the
doors to collect the money so I never
got that part but I felt so obligated
that I said I would do it that I kept
delivering the papers essentially for
free so that's where I started as an
entrepreneur my parents biggest
frustration was that I was epically lazy
and if they handed out gold medals for
being lazy I would have won I assure you
hands down there was a period in my life
where I would spend between two and
three hours in bed because it was warm
in bed and it was cold out of bed all
right that's true I actually did an
interview with Jocko willink if you guys
know him extreme ownership his book
totally blew me away and in the middle
of the interview I confessed that and he
said Tom don't worry we'll let you edit
that out and I said Jaco I don't I
actually don't want to edit that out
because right now the narrative about
what it means to be an entrepreneur
is to be naturally gifted and I call
total on that because I'm not
naturally gifted I don't have any
natural talents and all of us are born
as this lump of jelly that can't hold
its own head up that poos in its pants
and we all learned to do things and it's
that ability to specialize that makes us
great and the things that you choose to
put your time and energy into those are
going to be the things that allow you to
accomplish something but all of that is
a choice can you talk a little bit about
seeking power
yeah and it confused me when I first
heard it I'm not sure I even liked how
you said it at first until I understood
it and so can you talk to everybody
about seeking power and what that means
yeah this is another one of those things
that internally for me it's such a
beautiful concept that I was so
surprised the first time I said it out
loud and somebody was like oh that's
gross and I was like okay I need to
explain this yes so to me power is the
ability to close your eyes imagine a
world a beautiful world the world that
you want to exist open your eyes and
then be able to actually make that world
come true and so when I say I'm seeking
power I'm saying I'm seeking the skills
that will allow me to make the world a
better place it will whether that's to
be able to connect with people and build
a team and get other people excited
whether that's to be able to build a
business that generates enough funds to
improve the lives of the employees and
the people that we touch with great
products you know whatever that is like
to to be willing and excited by the
thought of going out and getting those
skills because those skills really are
powerful and to me it's like
people misunderstand power the way they
misunderstand money any moment you can
choose to believe something new about
yourself now the weird thing about
belief is as soon as you change that
belief it becomes true why that is I
will never quite understand what weird
Quirk of human evolution has left us in
a space where simply believing it makes
it true if you think you're dumb guess
what you're dumb
truly and you will act in accordance
with that belief and that should scare
the out of you because it scared
the life out of me and I saw myself
heading down a path that I did not want
to be on because I believed that I was
dumb I had a fixed mindset I used to
only apply for jobs where I knew I'd be
smarter than the person interviewing me
because I did not want to feel badly
about myself but you can imagine the
types of jobs that I got
I once lovingly referred to myself as
the king of remedial jobs
and I actually had pride in that because
what I built my sense of Pride around
was getting the job was always being
smart was being right and none of those
things were moving me towards my goals
now if you don't know this quote live by
it one can have no smaller or greater
Mastery the Mastery over oneself that's
Da Vinci Da Vinci did amazing things
with his life I wanted to do equally
amazing things with mine and if that's
the game that we're playing if I can
construct my belief system if I can
choose at any moment
to believe something that's more
empowering than I was believing the
moment before
and that that will actually find its way
into my actions
allow me to do things that I couldn't do
the moment before
then it's like that moment in The Matrix
where Neo realizes he knows kung fu
and that's like
about life to
the very fundamental purpose of life
is to find out how many skills I can
acquire that have utility
and then put that utility to the test in
service of something greater than myself
I used to say to myself all the time
you're gonna get rich or you're going to
die trying
and so starting as a copywriter I
started busting my ass step number one I
convinced my wife we're going to because
there were two other partners that hired
me
I'm gonna pick an apartment that's no
more than five minutes from either of
them
that way if they call me at two in the
morning I'll be there in five minutes
and they're gonna know no one else in
their company is as serious as me
and I'm gonna claw my way up this
company and I'm gonna get whatever job I
become the right person for and I'm
going to work my way up and by the time
we ended up selling that company I had
clawed my way through Sweat Equity into
owning 10 of the company and being the
chief marketing officer from starting as
the copywriter the person that everybody
asked who's the kid in the server room
was the only person that didn't have a
window they literally put me in the room
with all the computer servers
but starting from there I knew I could
wow people because I was willing to
grind it out
and that is one of the most valuable
things that anybody can do because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want another amazing Tom bill you video
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there